even in the depth of the morning of our
Sun it's hard for me to describe how
distressed we were over the outrage that
happened in Jerusalem the shedding of
innocent blood is against morality it's
against the Torah and Judaism it's
against the basis of our life in this
country the murderers of our children
whoever sent them whoever helped them
have incited towards that murder will
all be brought to justice but it will be
them and no innocent people
[Music]
no mother or father should go through
what we are going now and we share the
pain of the parents of Mohammed Abu
Khalil we truly hope that very soon the
peace and calm will come back all over
our country